and I hereby declare that said Jessica
Elizabeth Morden is duly elected as
Member of Parliament for Newport East
[Applause]
those dents can we just food please a
please there were 68 injected bulbs will
now make up an equation in Welsh as well
now the human made count with the with
the Tasha petrushka de leg meal with
cancer in Peter James Brown now council
critic where Yin Williams Gorman in meal
the encounter is dead
Jessica Elizabeth modern day that meal
with cancer pic web Cameron Thomas vixy
with cans with again I could ruin that
country in water Jessica Elizabeth
Morden where the guy Ethel I'm holiday
loss in it'll just do right cast me with
well thank you very much
Newport ease thank you for all as we
move voted labour in this not general
election on all those who took part no
matter what party you voted for a huge
huge privilege to be reelected for the
fourth time for this wonderful
constituency I look forward to going
back to work tomorrow with my team to
speak up a new computer absolutely have
the opportunity in Parliament can I
thank the returning offices the counters
all the staff all the work that they've
done a fantastic ero it can't be easy
and his staff can be easy going from a
local election straight into a general
elections well thanks to him and his
staff to also thank you to all the other
candidates as well for your the way
you've conducted this election I just
finally got to say a big huge thank you
for my team in your bodies led by my
fantastic agent the wonderful Deb Davis
we've just grown and grown
we have people welcome you nice mom
like a party for the first time
constituents who come to offer their
support and it's been absolutely
marvelous
I've completely in the Newport to bubble
at this count and I could I look forward
to seeing other results from welsh
labour constituencies and i would also
just like to end by saying a very big
thank you to my family and that goes for
the families of candidates everywhere
for Sean to Molly to be done to all my
family thank you very much